die sieger triumphieren große
militärparade in aserbaidschans
hauptstadt baku
der türkische präsident erdogan feiert
mit die schutzmacht hatte geholfen dass
aserbaidschan den erzfeind armenien im
kampf um die region berg karabach
besiegen konnte
die parade ist eine demütigung des
gegners stolz wird erbeutetes
armenisches kriegsgerät präsentiert und
türkische kampfdrohnen das zeichen ist
klar
die türkei ist eine macht im kaukasus
proteste in jerewan seit dem
waffenstillstand anfang november kommt
armeniens hauptstadt nicht zur ruhe
tausende hatten sich freiwillig dem
kampf um berg karabach angeschlossen
mehr als 2400 soldaten wurden getötet
ihr staatschef habe sie verraten meinen
sie den angriff aserbaidschans
provoziert und schließlich einen
unsicheren frieden ausgehandelt
[Musik]
um die region im südkaukasus kämpfen
aserbaidschan und armenien seit
jahrhunderten anfang der 90er erlangte
armenien die kontrolle über bergkarabach
und umliegende pufferzonen auf
aserbaidschanischem territorium sechs
wochen krieg im herbst haben die
machtverhältnisse umgekehrt jerewan das
große gebiete an baku zurückgeben
karbatschen und agdam sowie das
kampfgebiet um für soli kurz nach dem
waffenstillstandsabkommen reisen zwei
teams des zdf nach berg karabach eines
von baku kommend durch die gebiete die
aserbaidschan zurückerhalten hat und
eines von jerewan aus durch die regionen
die weiter unter armenischer kontrolle
bleiben sollen und nach kambodscha am
tag vor der übergabe an aserbaidschan
nichts als verbrannte erde soll dem
feind überlassen werden
arminia zünden ihre häuser an über ein
vierteljahrhundert lang lebten sie hier
in der republik bergkarabach die
internationalen nie anerkannt wurde und
doch heimat war nach der niederlage
fliegen die armenier zu tausenden
hinterlassen eine geisterstadt
nicole bereitet sich darauf vor sein
zuhause zu verlassen
als wir ihn um seine meinung bitten
fragte arminia erstmal ob er fluchen
dürfe
zur hölle
natürlich werden wir wieder kommen das
ist das land unserer großeltern
wir können denen das land nicht
überlassen vielleicht nicht gleich aber
in fünf oder zehn jahren holen wir es
uns zurück ein paar kilometer weiter
das kloster da die bank ein zufluchtsort
seit über 800 jahren die armenier
bezeichnen sich selbst als die erste
christliche nation
nun nehmen sie abschied der
klostervorsteher hat im krieg der 90er
selbst gekämpft
lieber wäre er mit einer waffe in der
hand sein kloster verteidigend gestorben
als es nun in aserbaidschan zu
überlassen erzählt uns pater johannes
liebl wenn die aserbaidschaner hierher
kommen werden sie alles zerstören
es sind vandalen sie werden alles dem
boden gleich machen
ich weiß dass ganz minuten sie werden
ihren christlichen ritualen aus auch
wenn aserbaidschan muss mich und
armenien christlich ist dies war kein
krieg der religionen sondern zweier
völker deren gemeinsame geschichte
getränkt ist von gegenseitigem unrecht
und wiederholten massa kann ich möchte
ihnen dafür danken dass mein sohn noch
leben
dass er jetzt ein kriegsheld ist wir
wollen sie danken
vladimir horowitz putin
der russische präsident hat den
waffenstillstand mit ausgehandelt un
friedenstruppen nach berg karabach
geschickt sie sollen das zusammenleben
von armenien und aserbaidschan an regeln
entlang neuer grenzen die noch nicht
genau abgesteckt sind etwas anderes aber
wird auf unserer reise sehr deutlich
russland hat seine präsenz im
südkaukasus gerade erfolgreich ausgebaut
und das gilt auch für die türkei durch
vermittlung ankaras bekommt unser team
aus istanbul visa für aserbaidschan von
der hauptstadt baku aus machen wir uns
auf den weg nach akten die nordöstliche
der an aserbaidschan übergebenen zonen
wir sind unterwegs mit amulett ibrahim
oft ein ex soldat und glühender patriot
er kämpfte im krieg anfang der neunziger
damals als sie alles an armenien
verloren auch diesmal meldete er sich
freiwillig zur front doch er wurde
abgelehnt er sei zu alt hieß es karabach
ist mein mutterland
die stadt schießt meiner heimat ab dann
ist meine heimat seit 28 30 jahren
konnten wir nicht mehr hierher kommen in
unser eigenes land kurz bevor wir die
ehemalige frontlinie überqueren treffen
wir ein paar zivilisten
sie haben mir nackt am gelebt einige
wurden dort geboren
sie flohen 1993 kurz bevor armenische
truppen die stadt einnahmen
heute kehren sie zurück in eine
geisterstadt
doch für unseren fahrer hamlet und die
anderen geht ein traum in erfüllung
agdam ist wieder unser sagen sie jetzt
sieht man nichts mehr
früher war drumm so wunderschön doch
alles ist kaputt
wir mussten damals alles im haus
zurücklassen
wir konnten nichts mitnehmen ich hatte
nur sandalen an meinen füßen
da hinten bin ich zur schule gegangen
sagt marianne aber an dem platz an dem
ihr haus stand ist nichts mehr zu finden
nur noch ruinen da wo früher mehr als
40.000 menschen lebten sie nennen es das
hiroshima des kaukasus
erst nach der eroberung adams durch die
armenischen streitkräfte 1993 wurde die
stadt geplündert und zerstört
offensichtlich war es zu gefährlich sie
zu besiedeln
denn die aserbaidschanischen kräfte
waren zu nahe und hätten die stadt hier
beschließen können und so hat man sich
dann wohl entschlossen alles mitzunehmen
was man irgendwie noch zu geld machen
konnte nur noch die moschee haben sie
stehen lassen
doch hamlet kennt die geschichten die
man sich erzählt von den armenischen
truppen in ihren beobachtungsposten in
der leeren statt
die haben hier drin tiere gehalten
möge gott sie dafür bestrafen in einem
muslimischen gebetsraum haben sie
schweine schafe und kühe gehalten
er selbst kämpfte als soldat gegen die
eroberer
die niederlage schmerzt ihn bis heute
umso größer sein triumph gefühlt wieder
in der moschee von akten beten zu können
maryam zeigt uns alte familienfotos ihr
mann und ihr bruder wurden bei den
angriffen vor 27 jahren verletzt sind
seitdem spurlos verschwunden
zwei von tausenden vermissten warum
haben sie uns getötet was hat mein mann
damals falsch gemacht mein sohn hier hat
mir internet videos gezeigt wie die
armenier geiseln ermorden
woher soll ich wissen ob sie meinen mann
damals nicht auch so gefoltert und
getötet haben
doch auch armenische soldaten starben in
aserbaidschan ischer gefangenschaft
kriegsverbrechen gab es auf beiden
seiten
weiter durch armenisch kontrollierte
gebiet nach step back and der hauptstadt
der 1993 ausgerufenen nie anerkannten
republik bergkarabach lange schlangen
jeden tag für finanzielle hilfen oder
auch nur plastikplanen um kaputte
fenster abzudichten
sechs wochen krieg haben viele
arbeitslos und zutiefst verunsicherte
zurückgelassen
5000 lebensmittelpakete gibt silva jeden
tag aus uns ist klar dass es wieder
krieg geben könnte niemand der hier lebt
ist sicher dass der krieg überhaupt
vorbei ist aber wir können nicht anders
als sie jedes mal zurückzukommen
die minensucher von halo just wollen das
land wieder bewohnbar machen
die hilfsorganisation zeigt uns ihr
ausbildungs gelände
normalerweise bringen sich hier
einheimischen bienen zu räumen doch im
oktober wurde ein nahe gelegenes
munitionslager bombardiert
die überreste mal explodiert mal
brandgefährlich
wir bringen das zu unserer zentralen
detonation stelle dort zerstören wir die
munition alle sprengmittel die wir
finden zerstören wir dort durch eine
explosion
ausgerechnet jetzt wo sie mehr
mitarbeiter brauchen als je zuvor können
die minenräumer niemanden ausbilden
eduard stammt aus japan kehrt er
arbeitet seit acht jahren für halo trust
wir haben uns damals gemeldet um
munition und minen zu entschärfen die
noch aus den 90ern übrig geblieben waren
aber jetzt hat uns der krieg viele neue
gefährliche gegenstände gebracht
deswegen klären die minenräumer auch oft
nichts anfassen was im garten schimmert
sofort expertenwissen im dorf neben dem
zerstörten waffenlager haben dass noch
nicht alle verinnerlicht
denn wer zeigt uns munitionsreste die um
sein neues haus herumliegen anfang
dezember sollte die einweihungsparty
stattfinden jetzt keine fenster ein
klaffendes loch im dachgeschoss wer's
frau hat angst dass der krieg erst der
anfang war
wir hatten uns armenien gibt es nur
wenige aber wir sind klug deswegen
wollen sie uns vernichten einen genozid
anfangen
sie meinen dass die türkei die treibende
kraft hinter aserbaidschans herbst fällt
sucht gewesen sei und das sehen viele
arminia so den wir in bergkarabach
begegnen
auf der aserbaidschanischen seite
bewegen wir uns in die südliche zone
richtung für soli in eines der am
heftigsten umkämpften gebiete am
kontrollpunkt richtung kampfgebiet wn
türkische fahnen
sie wissen wem sie diesen sieg auch zu
verdanken haben türkische drohnen und
militärhilfe zwangen armenien in die
knie unser fahrer hamlet der ex soldat
zeigt uns stolz zwei erbeutete
armenische panzerfahrzeuge schaut mal da
ist noch die ladung drin wir haben den
panzer mit voller munition erbeutet
sie haben alles da gelassen was sie
hatten und sind einfach davon gelaufen
die befreiten zonen sind gefährlich ist
ihr panzer und personen minen liegen
überall vergraben
minenräumer suchen und entschärfen die
heimtückischen waffen für uns das
deutsche fernseh team haben sie alles
vorbereitet um zu zeigen welche
tödliches erbe der feind hinterlassen
wir räumen die minen in zwei schritten
der erste ist die räumung der bewohnten
gebiete das wird wahrscheinlich und fünf
jahre dauern
in einem zweiten schritt klären wir auch
berggebiete und landwirtschaftsflächen
das dauert länger
wahrscheinlich so um die zehn jahre
[Musik]
beide seiten beklagen weit über 2000
tote
noch immer sind nicht alle opfer
geborgen auf der ladefläche eines
lastwagens liegen die verkohlten leichen
armenischer soldaten
vermutlich kamen die männer bei einem
drohnenangriff ums leben in einem krieg
der nur 44 tage dauerte
[Musik]
an der straße nach für soli dokumentiert
hamlet die spuren der angriffe auf die
stellungen der armenier gegen die
feuerkraft seiner armee hatten sie keine
chance
auf der armenischen seite der front den
nun kontakt linie heißt erreichen wir
nach toni hier treffen wir karen der 58
jährige war mit seiner einheit an der
front stationiert viele seiner kameraden
sterben ohne den waffenstillstand wären
sie jetzt alle tot ist sich karin sicher
wir haben gegen drei seiten gekämpft
aserbaidschan die türkei und deren
sollten sie können sich vorstellen wie
stark unser wille sein musste um 40 tage
lang gegen einen feind zu bestehen der
uns zahlenmäßig zu überlegen war in den
90ern stolzer sieger traut karen dem
waffenstillstand heute nicht seine
kalaschnikow vater immer griffbereit
dieser krieg gegen aserbaidschan war
anders als die beiden vorherigen in
denen er gekämpft hat im ersten krieg
haben wir hauptsächlich mit unseren
gewähren gekämpft aber jetzt ist diese
waffe quasi nutzlos
sie haben viel artillerie eingesetzt hat
und drohnen damit haben sie uns große
verluste beschert hand hat an der seite
seines vaters gekämpft jeder in
bergkarabach kenne jemanden der im krieg
gestorben sei erzählt er uns wenige
wochen nach seinem kriegseinsatz scheint
der junge arminia jede hoffnung auf eine
friedliche zukunft verloren zu haben
ich kann in dieser sache einfach nicht
optimistisch sein
ich glaube niemand erotisch und ich
glaube nicht dass dieser
waffenstillstand halten wird der
wiederaufbau hat begonnen
dächer werden repariert schutt
weggeräumt doch der ruhe
vertrauen sie nicht
am straßenrand entdecken wir ausstellung
bereit zum einsatz
falls aserbaidschan der feind angreift
hass und misstrauen bleiben
und das gilt auch für die
aserbaidschanische seite wir erfahren
dass bei unserem besuch in der stadt für
soli 1993 an armenien verloren nun
wieder zurückerobert wert über der ruine
des ehemaligen rathauses die
aserbaidschanische flagge auch für soli
ist eine geisterstadt wie akten seit 27
jahren am netz steigt durch die trümmer
der ehemaligen moschee
da war das minarett so groß wie das der
nada die armenier haben es zerstört die
moschee war sehr sehr groß das ist es
was sie damit getan haben kein stein
steht mehr auf dem anderen
am rande der stadt das ehemalige bezirks
hauptquartier der armenischen truppen
der einsatzstab hatte hier seinen sitz
hier hocken sie alle ihre offiziere ihre
na ja ich will keine schimpfwörter
verwenden da drüben war die werkstatt
und ihre küche
schweine haben sie dort gehalten
schweine wie sie selbst nationalisten
wie hamlet bestimmen den ton auf
afghanischer seite und sie sind es die
sieger die die regeln diktieren wollen
wie es unser präsident gesagt hat die
arminia können mit uns in unserem land
zusammenleben als bürger unseres landes
unter unserer flagge mit unseren plätzen
das aber ist kaum vorstellbar armenien
ist geschlagen aber nicht besiegt es
herrscht ein waffenstillstand kein
frieden jahrhunderte alte feindschaft
ist noch lange nicht begraben
[Musik]